- My next guest is an
award-winning journalist
we all know and love.
In her new BET show Disrupt & Dismantle,
she takes a deeper look at systemic racism
and the steps we can take
to achieve lasting change.
Check it out.
- Attacking the issues head on.
- Children are out here, and
fighting for their lives.
- [Soledad O'Brien] Making it right.
Is it as simple as money?
- Yes.
We need more funding.
- [Soledad O'Brien] Real action.
- She was absolutely denied
her basic human rights.
- [Soledad O'Brien] Standing
by is no longer an option.
- This shouldn't be happening.
And it's just wrong.
- [Voiceover] Disrupt and Dismantle,
hosted by Soledad O'Brien.
- Wow. Please welcome
Soledad O'Brien everybody.
(upbeat talk show music)
(audience cheering)
- I matched it to the blue on your dress.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I literally,
I literally just painted a,
my whole, my living room that color
'cause I think it's such a
great, peaceful great color.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- And it brightens everything up.
- You look beautiful.
- Thank you. Likewise.
And likewise. And likewise.
- Thank you for coming on the show.
So what made you wanna
do a show like this?
You wanna see change?
- [Soledad O'Brien] Yeah, and I think
we felt the time was right.
I think in the, the wake of
the killing of George Floyd,
I noticed, and I think a
lot of other people did too,
that the conversation
around race, and racism
was, was changing.
That people across the
board, not just black people,
but all people were like,
we need to figure this out.
- No, and it's actually a
really important time I think
to do it right now because
I think a lot of people
that didn't know things are happening.
Like that, you can't change them,
unless you know it exists, you know?
But you say it's, it's
important to highlight
how systems are often
the root of injustice,
so can you explain that?
- Yeah, well systems are complicated.
Right, in a way, it's
almost easier to say,
"Well that person did this,
and that person did this."
But systems are big and overwhelming
and how do you think about
the system that keeps people
in an unequal plane?
For example, my mom and
dad came to this country.
My mom was Afro-Cuban, black and Cuban.
My dad was white and Australian.
When they moved into their neighborhood,
no one would sell them a house
because they would not allow black people
to move into their neighborhood.
That, that's a system, right.
That's not even individuals.
That's a system that changed over time.
And so we wanted to both look at,
at history, what put
these systems in place,
and then also look at,
okay well if it's a system
and it's big and complicated,
I think there's a real
tendency to be like, "Well that's just.
That's overwhelming."
- [Kelly Clarkson] Overwhelming, yeah.
- I can't manage that by myself.
And we wanted to show
people how you could disrupt
and dismantle systems.
What specific things you could do.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
actually love that about this
because you're not only
providing what the problems are,
you're providing solutions right?
- Yeah, and it's really
easy to admire problems
like yeah, well, that is bad.
That is depressing.
- [Kelly Clarkson] But like
what the hell do you do?
- [Soledad O'Brien] Exactly. Exactly.
And so we wanted to provide
a real, you know, map.
There are ways, and
sometimes those ways are,
get involved in politics,
figure out zoning.
Understand who you're
elected officials are.
Can you name them?
Do you have their numbers?
What are your rights
in terms of what you're
trying to change in your community.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah. Agreed, agreed.
Well, one of the episodes
focuses on infant mortality.
So can you tell us more about that?
- [Soledad O'Brien] Yeah.
You know, if you look at the disparity
between black women and
white women when it comes
to maternal mortality,
and infant mortality.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I have
actually heard of this.
- The numbers are terrible.
Black women are three to
four times more likely,
three to four times more
likely to die in childbirth.
It mean, it's, it's crazy.
So we wanted to understand that.
And what you really see
pretty clearly pretty quickly
is that there are these sort of racial
and systemic racism that
sort of influences outcomes
for women and also their infants as well,
the infant mortality
numbers are terrible too.
And so we wanted to
explore what was happening
around infant mortality.
The stories are terrible,
and they go from women
not getting good access to health care,
women living in healthcare deserts,
where they're just not anywhere close
to good places to get healthcare.
And also, a lot of black
women reported doctors
just not really listening to them.
There're lots of studies
that say doctors and others
believe black women have a
higher tolerance for pain.
So we're really interested
in exploring, well what
exactly is involved?
Sometimes it's just access
to, to better systems
around funding for healthcare,
et cetera, et cetera.
So we looked at this and thought,
okay, here's the problem,
it's fully documented.
We know a lot of the
reasons. How do you solve it?
There was nothing unusual
about Kim's pregnancy,
and the delivery was normal.
Yet, three days after giving birth,
Kim's health took a drastic turn.
- [Family Member] Like
she couldn't see well,
and she kept having a lot of headaches.
We had talked to this doctor
about sending her to Memphis
several times trying to figure out
what was going on with her.
But he decided not to send her.
So she continued to deteriorate.
- Wow, welcome back.
That was a clip from Disrupt & Dismantle.
And I'm here with the host
of the show Soledad O'Brien.
Give it up for her everybody.
(audience applauding)
So in that episode, Soledad examined
the infant mortality rates in Mississippi.
We have two of the women from that episode
joining us right now.
Everybody please welcome
sisters Notoya and Nikitra.
(audience applauding)
Hi ladies.
- Hi.
- Hey.
- Well first of all, I
have to start with this,
you both look beautiful with
the colors you're wearing
and your smiles are gorgeous.
- Oh well, thank you.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
I was like, "Wow, y'all
look like little lights
on the screen."
Well Notoya, I'll, I'll start with you.
You started researching infant mortality
after losing your baby, right?
Can you tell us what happened?
- [Notoya] Yeah sure.
So in February of 2016,
I was about 25 weeks pregnant at the time,
and I started experiencing
some like upper-quadrant pain.
So fast forward, you know, we
went to the emergency room.
Of course I was quickly seen,
but in a matter of literally minutes,
we were, you know, we were, we realized
that things were taking
a turn for the worst.
I was told that I would be transferred
to Jackson Mississippi,
which is two hours away from Starkville.
And I would probably deliver there
or stay there until delivery.
And so, I later found out that
the University of
Mississippi Medical Center
is the only level four NICU in this state.
And two days later, I delivered Jordan
via emergency C-Section
at 25 weeks, one day,
weighing a whopping one
pound and one ounce.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Wow.
- [Notoya] And so, after Jordan
passed at eight months old,
my husband and I started
thinking about, you know,
we knew that we couldn't
prevent this from happening
to another child, but if
we could ease the burden
of a family going through it,
then that's what, you know, we were like,
maybe we were chosen for
this path for a reason
and so what will we do going forward?
And so in combination with the
University of Mississippi Medical Center
in Jackson Mississippi, we
formed a family advisory board.
And so it's made up
of current NICU parents,
former NICU parents.
Nurses, hospital
administration, social workers.
And we basically serve as a support
for, you know, parents going
through the NICU journey.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's amazing.
I was literally gonna
say, "Power in numbers."
Like making that, having that network
of people that support from, from people,
especially from the professionals
that you have in that,
that network environment too, telling you,
you know their expertise,
this might be happening,
this might be, you know what I'm saying?
Like having that group to kind of go to.
Nikitra you, you've looked at
the infant mortality crisis
from another perspective right?
- [Nikitra] Yeah.
So, I, I've been in public
health for about 13 years now,
and most of my career has been
in sexual and reproductive health.
And so, when you think
about reproductive health,
that of course includes
reproductive rights,
and pregnancy labor delivery.
I kind of took my family
lens off and started trying
to look at this from a
public health perspective
because this wasn't just
a strange turn of events
for our family, it's
happening across the country.
And so, I was trying to figure out how,
how do we fix this?
What do we do?
And so I started looking at the system.
And that's where the issue lies.
We can tell a woman to say, "I'm hurting.
I need this. I feel this way."
But if a doctor's not listening to her,
then that's a problem.
If we have our moms healthy,
then we can get our babies healthy.
But, in order to do that,
we really have to address systemic racism,
and all of those barriers
that keep a woman
from being able to navigate that system
of healthcare in a way that gets her out
on the other side and gives her
this great experience of childbirth.
We, we always see childbirth in this,
you know, this great experience.
But, it's so complex for black mothers
that we don't get that opportunity.
And so that's the lens
that I look at it from.
- That's what I'm, that's
why it's unfortunate
that doctors really don't listen
because it is so different.
Even with the same woman,
my two pregnancies were very different.
You have no idea, like
what's, what's happening.
And it could be a, a plethora of,
of things, you know, happening.
So I, I'm, I'm so sorry and I,
I wanna say this so.
Soledad, you, you see hope that,
the infant mortality rate
can be reduced, right?
- Yeah, look at these two sisters
who could be doing a 100 other things
and instead have decided
to dedicate their lives
to making change, because they know
it's not just their story,
it's the story of a lot of black women.
A lot of women, and a lot of black women.
And I think there's always
hope when you have people
first,
deciding to have a difficult conversation.
What is the data?
What are the facts?
What do we know?
In Mississippi, they track this now,
because people deserve
to understand the data.
And really it's what our
whole entire show is about.
We deserve to understand the data,
and after you do that,
you can say, "Okay, now we
know, what do we do to change?"
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah. And
how is information ever bad?
And that's my thing, is
like, the more information
we, the more conversations,
the more information we have,
the, the more we can progress.
- Yeah.
- Thank you for doing what you're doing
to help, you know, not only
your family, but everyone.
You're trying to, to affect
change, that ripple effect
is gonna hit everyone, not
just your, your family.
So it's, it's a really cool
thing what you're doing.
And, and like Soledad said,
thank you so much for
taking the time to do that,
'cause you're be, you
could be doing anything
with your lives.
So this is really important.
So thank you.
(people applauding)
- Thank you.
- Thank you for having us.
- Thank you so much.
- Absolutely. Absolutely.
Well, everybody Disrupt & Dismantle
airs Wednesdays on BET.